en los últimos años la presencia de
china en el continente africano ha
crecido vertiginosamente y ya en 2009
superó a los eeuu como primer socio
comercial de la zona desde el año 2000
el comercio bilateral entre china y
africa se ha multiplicado por 22 hasta
superaron los 220 mil millones de
dólares para hacernos una idea de la
enorme apuesta de china cabe destacar
que hoy su inversión directa es mayor en
áfrica que los mismísimos estados unidos
es en este contexto en el que muchas
personas que se olvidan que el comercio
nunca ha sido una fuente de pobreza
están mostrando sistemáticamente su
preocupación acerca de los efectos esta
invasión puede tener en las economías de
los países africanos ácido y uva ahora
con los chinos tomamos todos los
préstamos posibles y para todos los
proyectos son ellos los que gestionan no
hay ningún control hay numerosos mitos
acerca de que mueve a china al gigante
asiático hoy vamos a tratar de desmontar
los tres principales los tres más
recurrentes
mito número 1 china destroza la economía
de áfrica con sus productos baratos
las estadísticas no avalan en modo
alguno este mito y es que gracias en
buena medida el incremento de la
inversión extranjera directa entre las
que se encuentran claro está la china el
crecimiento económico de áfrica se ha
disparado en los últimos 15 años así
según datos del banco mundial entre el
año 2002 y el año 2011 la pobreza se
redujo en un 20%
y esta es una dinámica que se está
acelerando en buena medida gracias a la
llegada de productos low cost de china
que están incrementando el poder
adquisitivo de los consumidores
africanos y les está permitiendo
dedicarse a aquellas actividades donde
son realmente competitivos en like the
chinese me gusta la tienda china por los
colores los materiales y sobre todo los
acabados y encima es asequible el uso
del saldo estatut en cualquier caso como
decíamos china y ya el primer socio
comercial de la región y la creciente
demanda de sus más de mil millones de
habitantes está aumentando las
exportaciones y las ganancias de las
empresas africanas
además ya muchas empresas chinas
plantean iniciar procesos de
internacionalización y deslocalización y
estableciéndose en áfrica una tierra
mira gracias a las relaciones que se han
establecido tampoco podemos olvidar los
importantes proyectos de infraestructura
que china está desarrollando por toda
áfrica proyectos entre los que podemos
encontrar puertos como el de lamu en
kenia aeropuertos como el de maputo
mozambique o líneas de ferrocarril como
la que está llamada a conectar kenia
uganda y ruanda todos ellos proyectos
estratégicos esenciales para el
desarrollo económico y que requieren
cientos y cientos de millones de dólares
para su ejecución además claro está de
tecnología y requerimientos técnicos
y de ahí hoy las calles y el skyline de
maputo están a pleno rendimiento una de
las últimas joyas de la capital de
mozambique que es el nuevo y más grande
hotel cinco estrellas detrás de él se
encuentra la empresa china de
construcción anhui que desde 1996 ha
desarrollado las obras más importantes
del gobierno como el aeropuerto
internacional y el estadio nacional en
esta línea en el marco del foro de
cooperación áfrica china el pasado mes
de diciembre el presidente chino xi
jinping comprometió ni más ni menos que
60 mil millones de dólares para
estimular la industria y la agricultura
en el continente negro así como para
desarrollar infraestructuras de todo
tipo puertos aeropuertos carreteras
núcleos logísticos redes eléctricas y un
largo etcétera
mito número 2 china utiliza su propia
mano de obra
es cierto que hay más de un millón de
chinos trabajando en áfrica y que tanto
china como sus empresas suelen trasladar
a sus propios trabajadores especialmente
si hablamos de técnicos para realizar
los proyectos en este continente pero
los datos también nos muestran otra
realidad por ejemplo en el caso de kenia
uno de los mayores receptores de capital
chino y para el cual tenemos datos tiene
dignos bueno pues las estadísticas para
este país nos muestran que es las
empresas si las contratan más
trabajadores keniatas ya trabajadores en
el android low cost 800 trabajadores
locales están trabajando aquí son parte
de los más de 25 mil quinientas
empleados para el proyecto como parte
del acuerdo entre kenia china la
compañía está impartiendo formación
especializada a los locales así el 74
por ciento de los puestos de trabajo
jornada completa y el 93 por ciento de
los puestos de trabajo a tiempo parcial
caen en manos de trabajadores africanos
tan corruptos mismo en google y me ha
gustado este tipo de trabajo desde
pequeño
quiero aprender y poder abrir mi propia
compañía algún día mismo y de hecho el
pasado año la mayoría de las empresas
chinas establecidas en este país tenían
planes para sustituir a mano de obra
china por mano de obra química y esto
porque pues muy sencillo simplemente
porque les resultaba más barato
mito número 3 china simplemente pretende
apropiarse de los recursos naturales de
áfrica
durante 1998 y el 2012 más de 2.000
empresas se establecieron invirtieron en
49 países de áfrica hoy hay más de 4000
proyectos de inversión ejecutándose en
todo el continente y la mayor parte de
ellos corresponden a empresas privadas y
no a empresas estatales dependientes de
pectina además lejos de lo que podríamos
esperar los proyectos de inversión no se
centran en las materias primas sino que
son los sectores de servicios y
manufacturas los que aglutinan el mayor
número de proyectos simple y llanamente
negocios de influencia y vale
probablemente también control político
pero en definitiva nada diferente de lo
que han buscado las potencias
occidentales durante muchísimos años
efectivos lo que ha hecho china
diferente es muy simple vinieron y nos
dijeron necesitamos nuestras materias
primas necesitamos nuestro petróleo
vuestro cobre y para asegurar el
suministro por cinco o diez años porque
los chinos tienden a pensar en plazos
más largos estaremos encantados de daros
préstamos los cuales vais a devolvernos
no con dinero sino con vuestras materias
primas podéis construir carteras trenes
podéis construir así vuestras
a sus propios o lo que además parece que
en este caso la variable fundamental la
más importante son los negocios y es que
tenemos que pensar que áfrica va a ser
el continente que más va a crecer del
siglo 21 y ya entre el año 2001 y año
2010 6 de las 10 economías que más
crecieron de todo el mundo se
localizaban en este continente y no
estamos hablando de excepciones el
crecimiento medio de la mayoría de las
naciones africanas osciló entre el 5 y
el 6 por ciento en la última década
además áfrica es un continente inmenso y
equiparable a la suma de europa estados
unidos china la india y argentina que
concentra el 60 por ciento de las
tierras cultivables y al menos el 40%
las reservas de oro el 30 por ciento de
los depósitos minerales y el 10 por
ciento del gas y el petróleo
convencional conocidos todo ello nos
muestra el enorme potencial que tiene
este continente
sainz es decir si prefieres de chinese
pero lo que el trabajo que es cierto que
existen dudas razonables sobre la
calidad y la conveniencia de muchas de
las infraestructuras que china promueve
sobre el cuidado del medio ambiente el
respeto a los derechos laborales y los
efectos de apuntalar a regímenes
dictatoriales y corruptos pero nadie
dijo que el camino hacia la próspera
fuese muy fácil ni rápido que pensáis
vosotros conseguirán las inversiones y
el comercio con china desarrollar este
continente caer a áfrica en manos del
gigante asiático espero que te haya
gustado este vídeo si ha sido así
suscríbete al canal un saludo y hasta la
próxima